kita und schulschließungen bisher waren
das einzelfall entscheidungen und das
wird auch erst mal so bleiben
beim treffen der kultusminister heute
wurden ja keine bundesweit
flächendeckenden schulschließungen
beschlossen aber es wurde auch gesagt
das ist die vielleicht bald geben könnte
was bedeutet das jetzt für alle
berufstätigen eltern bei mir ist felix
zimmermann aus unserer abteilung recht
und justiz felix wenn jetzt die schulen
und kitas tatsächlich dicht machen und
eltern nicht wissen wie sie ihre kinder
betreuen sollen würden sie dann einfach
zu hause bleiben
unter umständen ja vater oder mutter
aber eben unter umständen und die erste
voraussetzung ist dass es keine
anderweitige betreuungsmöglichkeit gibt
ja und da denkt man natürlich zuerst mal
die großeltern und das ist ja gerade die
risikogruppe wo die behörden sagen
lieber kein kontakt zu kindern
deswegen wird man sagen das ist
unzumutbar und eltern können in der
regel zu hause bleiben vater oder mutter
allerdings nur dass die zweite
einschränkung für wenige tage die
rechtsprechung nimmt meist fünf tage an
und was passiert jetzt wenn die schulen
zum beispiel länger schließen ja dann
steht der arbeitnehmer blöd da denn ist
es so wenn der arbeitnehmer selbst in
quarantäne ist oder das kind selbst
krank ist dann gibt es gesetzlich
umfassende entschädigungsregelung aber
für den fall dass die schule schließt
eben nicht und da muss der arbeitnehmer
urlaub nehmen solange noch welchen hat
mit der kammer hat dann drohen auf jeden
fall gehaltseinbußen was ist denn mit
selbständigen die haben es noch
schwieriger ist leider in sind freie
mitarbeiter in einem dienstverhältnis
aber wäre ganz normal selbstständig ist
ein betrieb für den gelten diese regeln
nicht dort gibt es zwar auch
entschädigungszahlen wenn man ein
unternehmen hat dann wird man
entschädigt wenn man unter quarantäne
selbst steht für kinder gibt es keine
regelung wäre die betreuung muss als
selbständiger der geht leer aus
vielen dank felix für diese einschätzung